hi everyone i'm jennifer zabasaja of
bloomberg news thank you
so much for joining us so this is a
really important conversation that we
are about to have even before joe biden
named senator kamala harris as his vice
presidential running mate
several women were preparing for the
inevitable
how the media how everyone really would
would have a double standard of female
candidates
versus male candidates and it's part of
the reason why i asked these two guests
to come
today to speak with me a little bit
about this so joining me today is
time's up ceo and president tina chen
and also editor at large of the 19th
aaron haynes how's it going both of you
it's going great happy black women's
equal pay day
august that's the point it takes this
long for black women
to earn what white men make yeah it's
yes it's something that i do want to get
into with both of you but aaron i wanted
to start with you first
even before senator harris was named as
the vice presidential pick you spoke
with people who said
a black candidate was a requirement not
a recommendation
can you just tell us in your opinion
what does she bring to this ticket
yeah well i mean obviously this is a
historic pick with her being uh the
first black woman the first woman of
south asian indian descent
being on this ticket uh but really what
she brings is a combination of her
qualifications and lived experience
uh to the ticket you heard uh her
alluding to some of that
yesterday giving a nod to the heroic and
ambitious women that had come
before her uh you know but this is
somebody who you know has already been
you know a trailblazer in in her
political career and and as we sit here
today
is the highest uh ranking black uh
woman elected official in the country
and so
you know i think that we have seen uh
her also making history with lone black
woman on the campaign trail in the 2020
democratic presidential
primary and you know in this pandemic uh
has been somebody who has
centered marginalized communities
raising issues about you know
unemployment benefits
uh eviction uh moratoriums uh
asking for uh you know racial data uh in
terms of this
global public health crisis and how
black folks who we know are being
disproportionately affected
uh by the coronavirus uh you know having
that
in writing and so that those resources
can be appropriately
uh distributed to those communities and
so i think those were really
among the criteria that joe biden was
considering
uh you know when he was trying to choose
from among the very uh
qualified capable and talented women uh
who were on
that list yeah and and tina i want to
ask you what was your reaction to
seeing the two of them for the first
time yesterday well it was thrilling
you know i i i would say this is a
historic moment for our country
even regardless of your party
affiliation you know this
this is real progress and just seeing a
black and
api woman standing up there you know
along with you know an incredible man as
a leader
vice president biden who's going to lead
us out of this pandemic
crisis economic crisis racial justice
reckoning that this country is going
through right now we need
these two leaders who can combine their
talents and address all of those issues
but mark my words we know what's coming
for her and
as we are saying it times up we have her
back because we
know what is coming and it has already
happened you know it just
you know it doesn't take even an hour
for the
racial misogynistic attacks to come her
way
and we're not going to stand for it as
women leaders in this country
yeah and your group at time's up was
very immediate to come out with we have
her back tell us a little bit about
how it came about and what exactly
you're planning on doing throughout this
election season
well for the last oh i apologize we have
for the last couple of couple weeks you
know we have many women leaders have
been talking
because we've lived this movie before we
have been here before we've seen what if
what has happened
to women leaders um and they've been
attacked and we weren't going to stand
for it let it go by unanswered this time
because when it happens you know when
women are called
nasty or their ambition is you're denied
or they talk about what they wear you
know we don't see women as leaders then
and it's not just as leaves our country
it's leaders you know as a ceo of a
company it's the
restaurant manager the server who wants
to become a restaurant manager
doesn't get seen in that leadership
position um so this affects our entire
culture
so we aren't going to stanford anymore
we're going to stand up and do it we
issued a memo to editorial rooms
last thursday night it didn't take 24
hours last weekend
for the new york times to run a headline
about wrist corsages
and the vice presidential you know
selection and the la times to liken
this to the bachelor and then you now
see
in less than 24 hours the attacks coming
at kamala harris
the other thing that happened in the
last 24 hours was the speaker of the
house
being called the b word and the gop
leaders letting that go by
this is all about demeaning and trying
to bring down women leaders so that we
aren't able to ascend to leadership and
a lot of the misinformation
is really spread through social media
right and then it just gets picked up
and
amplified aaron i wonder if someone who
works in a newsroom
what are ways that you know people can
you know
fairly criticize some of these female
candidates without actually adding to
a lot of the noise that is out there
yeah well you know aside from starting a
whole new newsroom which is what we did
uh you know this year tina we got the
memo uh back in january when we launched
the 19th uh you know because we had seen
uh frankly uh that gendered coverage not
only in the 2016
election but in presidential cycle after
cycle uh
you know just really focusing on you
know personality traits questions of
electability
as if you know the definition of
electability is is not getting elected
right
uh and so you know really yes i mean i
think that that's it
focusing on on qualifications and really
just taking a a moment to think
uh you know before uh asking uh women
candidates whether they're running for
president or anywhere uh up or down the
ticket
uh is this a question that i would ask a
man uh that
was running for office and if the answer
is no then you know why is that question
being
uh posed uh to the woman that is running
for that office and so i think that
that's a starting point uh but i also
think that frankly part of the problem
uh which you know we are
certainly attempting to be a solution
for at the 19th
is the reality that three-fourths of the
stories that are written
and the gatekeepers who are are doing
political journalism are
white and or male and or both uh and so
when you have that
uh it it it is at least part of the
explanation for
uh why these narratives persist uh but
you are seeing so much pushback both
inside and outside
of newsrooms uh to to really kind of uh
make sure that these kinds of tropes and
these kinds of narratives
uh have no place uh in 2020 election and
beyond in our political journalism
yeah and it's important to tina i think
to mention we have her back is
bipartisan right it's not just about
carmel harris and the democrats you also
have people on the republican side who
are supporting this right
oh absolutely i mean this let's be clear
you know gender discrimination
and misogyny knows no partisan line
it happens in you know all across the
spectrum and when it happens we're going
to call it out
because voters need to understand what
they're seeing you know
some of these some of this language is
so coded they don't even realize it
you know when president trump calls
kamal harris phony
you know it sounds like that's not a
sexist word but guess what
it actually plays into the idea that
she's a phony because women don't belong
running for leadership right it it is
sending that message
and it's sending that message not just
to kamala harris it's sending it to
our daughters and to our sons about how
they see women in leadership
and that's why culture change you know
deep culture change requires us
to call this out so the voters see it
and understand it and are informed when
they take make their vote
this november and that beyond november
we begin to see women leadership for
what it is which is we deserve to be
there we deserve to be in the white
house
we just deserve to be at the top of
these companies
and our country is going to be better
for it
and finally just to both of you do you
worry i mean we're living in this age
where cancer culture right is is
such a huge thing do you worry that
you know people could this could lead to
maybe people trying to cancel
out certain people and and fueling that
even more or
um i wonder what your take is on that
well you know
at least at times up and up we have our
back we're focused on what words are
being used
right and change your language and
change your viewpoint
you know don't don't we we want you you
know to news editors
you know to actually think more and use
different language
not exit the stage um and we want people
to be
thoughtful so we're focused on the words
on what's being used and what's being
said
and do better and we're not saying don't
criticize folks you know as aaron said
right
talk about the issues talk about her
record right and if you disagree with
those
have at it but don't talk about her
clothes don't talk about her personal
past
don't talk about you know her husband um
and
don't you know even if you think you're
cute don't make allusions to the
bachelor
do not do that yeah and i would just say
i mean look
at the 19th we're we're about cancelling
uh the myth of electability and and and
you know questions of likability and
anything that is not you know
focused on uh what what this should be
about which is
uh the news and information that voters
are going to need to make an informed uh
decision about who they're going to vote
for uh in in
less than 90 days from now absolutely
and aaron just finally you're speaking
with senator harris tomorrow
is there anything that you can share
with us uh what can we expect
well i think that you can expect a
robust conversation uh we
expect that uh our uh conversation with
senator harris which is going to be our
final keynote at the end of our virtual
summit
uh that has already been spectacular and
has been been going on this entire week
to to really recognize
uh the upcoming uh centennial of the
19th amendment for which our newsroom is
named but obviously with an asterisk
for the omission of the black women who
were excluded uh from
access to that franchise for another
four decades until the passage of the
voting rights act
of 1965 and so uh you know we're going
to have an extended conversation
with senator harris around a range of
issues including you know why
uh she uh you know the case that she
made for for why she uh was was
a fit for this role uh what she plans to
bring to this ticket
uh you know and frankly those questions
of race and and gender and
her response to them among other things
so i hope that everybody will tune in
it's going to be uh tomorrow at
2 p.m eastern and you can register for
free at summit.19news.org so i hope that
everybody will join us
and i love that you're doing this erin i
love i love the 19th and i
love love that senator harris is going
to be at your first ever summit
congratulations so much tina we're super
excited
that the vice presidential uh nominee a
woman on the ballot for the third time
uh in vice presidential
uh politics for a major party and the
first time that a woman of color is
joining that ticket so uh yes it is very
exciting indeed that she will be
joining our new but mighty uh newsroom
uh to discuss these issues tomorrow
amazing well thank you both so much for
this conversation
please come back because we have 81 or
something day so i think we're going to
have a lot more to talk about
yeah uh editor at large of the 19th
aaron haines and
time's up ceo and president tina chen
thank you both for your time
thank you take care everybody